Il y a 15 ans, il y a 10 ans, quand je graffais dans la rue,
il y avait la police qui débarquait,
les gens, ils m'insultaient, ils me criaient dessus.
Aujourd'hui, 20 ans après, ça a évolué en fait.
Quand t'as une bombe et que tu peins,
les gens regardent ce que tu fais,
ils regardent plus le fait que tu aies une bombe.
Tu vois que c'est vraiment addictif, quoi.
Tu peux pas t'empêcher de laisser ta trace,
de faire un petit tag, de faire un petit truc
et de regarder l'espace
qu'en termes de spots que tu pourrais peindre.
Tu vois ?
Le graffiti, c'est la liberté.
Que ce soit vandal ou pas vandal.
Paris couvert de tags,
Paris massacré, retourné, cartonné
comme disent les tageurs.
On s'amuse productivement,
en étant productifs.
Je pense pas que ça se disait "productivement".
- Non, non. - C'est pas grave.
- Faudra... au montage.
On s'amuse tout en étant productifs !
Tu vois, il y a des petits branleurs qui vont passer, ils vont dire :
"Oh, il y a un tag, il s'appelle comment ?"
Psy.
Ils vont passer 10 mètres plus loin,
ils vont revoir la même chose
et à la fin de la soirée, bourrage de crâne, prise de tête.
"Oh, mais qui c'est celui-là ?"
Et comme ça, ils vont nous connaître.
Les toiles, les gens, ils les gardent chez eux,
les murs ça se voit, quoi.
Si t'as un truc à dire
de valable,
je sais pas, essaye de le mettre sur un mur.
Je m'appelle Jay, JayOne,
je suis un ancien graffeur.
Ce qu'on appelle le pionnier du graffiti, ici en France.
Nous sommes à Stalingrad.
Alors là, vous voyez une poste,
mais à l'époque c'était un terrain vague.
Un des importants lieux du graffiti
puisque c'est ici que le graff s'est vraiment installé.
Lorsque la culture hip-hop est arrivée en France,
la plupart des jeunes, ils dansaient,
globalement, il y avait très peu de rappeurs,
très peu de DJs, c’était beaucoup la danse
et très peu de graffeurs.
Ça ressemble aux mêmes ambiances
qu’il y avait dans les ghettos noirs et latinos de New York,
là où le graff, il est né, on va dire.
Les jeunes qui étaient issus de l’immigration
et des minorités invisibles,
ils se sont retrouvés dans cette culture,
ça a éveillé chez eux des envies d’exprimer qui ils étaient,
d’où ils venaient et quelles étaient leurs préoccupations.
Ces gens-là, ils se réunissent tous
et puis ils forment ce qu’ils n’avaient pas avant :
une culture.
La culture, si tu veux,
comme nos ancêtres auraient pu l'avoir
mais sur le bitume.
C'est-à-dire on est dans le béton,  autant faire avec.
L'illégalité, c’est une façon  encore de dire
que ces gens sont hors la loi
alors que pour moi, c’est plus une forme de résistance.
On habite dans ces endroits  tout pourris
donc c’est à nous qu’il appartient
de pouvoir faire de la pub comme on l’entend
donc ça peut être à travers les graffs,
ou de les embellir et de faire des expos comme on l’entend
sur des murs.
Peut-être que dans 50 ou 100 ans,
quand ils regarderont en arrière,
ils réaliseront qu'on était
un groupe intelligent d'artistes
et qu'on en a bavé.
J’ai envie de taguer partout,
j’ai envie de taguer partout, j’ai envie de taguer partout.
T'as l'impression que tu te bats contre un format,
quelque chose de balèze.
T'as évacué tout ce que t'avais sur toi,
tout ce que t'avais comme pensées.
Je m'appelle Michaël Eveno, "Grems".
J’ai fait du graff parce qu'il y avait un truc
qui s'appelait le hip-hop,
c’étaient plusieurs disciplines
et c’était la seule alternative  qu’on avait pour avoir une activité,
parce que malheureusement,
la rue n’offrait aucune activité à cette époque-là.
Liberté.
La liberté mec !
Moi, ce que j’ai aimé,
c’est de prendre une bombe et faire un truc.
Alors j’ai autant aimé le côté illégal que le côté légal,
donc j’ai fait les deux.
Puis on grandit, on a des problèmes avec la police.
Moi, le côté vandal,
j’ai dû malheureusement un petit peu lâcher,
puisqu’à cause du rap et à cause de tout ça,
j’étais un peu grillé et connu.
La réalité, c’est que j’ai des enfants
et que je peux pas leur dire que je reviens pas
pour un tag la nuit quoi.
Donc j’en fais mais un petit peu moins que les gens.
Voilà, je crois que j'ai presque fini.
Je dois avoir fini même.
On est tous pareils, les graffeurs,
quel que soit le style qu’on fait,
on a besoin d’aller peindre gratuitement sur les murs.
C’est vital,  c’est vital parce que c’est le premier amour en fait,
tu vois ?
Ce qui est vachement cool, c’est que quand tu peins,
on va dire dehors ou dans un espace urbain
ou dans un truc qui est comme ça,
en fait tu crées une interaction directement
avec les habitants et l’environnement.
Et il n’y a pas de mensonge
et je trouve que c’est quelque chose qui est vachement pur, tu vois.
Le graff, c’est un truc d’initiés,
mais c’est le graffiti qui est entre initiés.
C’est les vandals, en fait, ils parlent qu’entre vandals.
Ça s’adresse pas aux mamies.
Alors que la mamie, quand elle voit un truc
qui est un petit peu bien dessiné,
elle est là, elle kiffe, elle fait : "Ouais, c’est cool".
En fait, la clé, c'est que tu fasses du légal ou de l'illégal,
plus t'es visible et tu prends ton temps,
plus les gens ils pensent que t'as l'autorisation.
T'étales tes affaires,
t'arrives en mode terrain conquis.
Mon nom d'artiste, c'est Kashink.
Ça fait presque 15 ans que je fais de la peinture dehors.
Effectivement, j’ai une inspiration des masques
parce que c’est une culture qui est mondiale,
c’est-à-dire que tous les humains de toutes les cultures du monde
ont une tradition de masques.
Pour moi, c’était important de pouvoir faire quelque chose
que je puisse partager
qui puisse être compris des gens qui vont passer.
La moustache, c’est vraiment le grand classique.
Ça fait presque 6 ans que je la porte vraiment tous les jours.
Ça surprend toujours de voir des femmes
faire des choses qui ne sont pas censées être
des choses de femme.
Tu vois une meuf en train de peindre,
est-ce que tu te dis direct : "Ah ouais, c’est méga féministe" ?
Tu vas voir ma gueule, tu vas penser féminisme,
tu vas penser queer, tu vas penser non-binarité,
ça se voit.
Si tu connais les sujets, pour moi, c'est acquis.
Si tu les connais pas
et que tu sais même pas ce que ça veut dire,
eh bien, tu vas voir ma face et tu vas peut-être te dire :
"Ah tiens, c’est possible de faire ça",
"Ah tiens il y a une meuf qui peint, j’ai vu ça aujourd’hui".
Faire des trucs interdits.
Ça, ça a vraiment été
une de mes premières  inspirations, aussi.
Faire un truc qui soit illégal
mais qui apporte une espèce de surprise
dans un espace où les gens  passent, habitent, etc.
Plus j’ai eu des commandes de murs,
plus j’ai eu des sollicitations pour exposer en galerie,
plus j’ai eu envie de faire de l’illégal à coté.
Parce que j’avais besoin de cette dynamique-là.
J'irais pas faire un graff sur un papier, tu vois.
Mais par contre, tout ce que tu recherches
et ce que tu vas faire et ce que tu vas prendre
dans le graffiti et dans la peinture,
sur papier, c'est le concentré,
c'est le résultat final, on va dire.
C'est la fin quoi.
Là, par exemple,
je suis en train de travailler sur une expo que je fais à Paris.
Je suis là-dessus, donc en fait là,
je suis en train de travailler les matières,
on va dire les mouvements, les skills.
Le graffiti, c'est libre,
on s'en fout de faire un truc bien ou pas bien.
On prend la photo ou pas, on l'efface ou pas.
C'est rapide.
La toile, on l'efface pas, c'est...
Elle est là, elle est là quoi.
Le festival, c'est un concept avant d'être un lieu
et ce concept, c'est autour de la couleur
et autour des styles des gens.
On veut montrer le spectre de ce qu'est le street art,
le plus large possible.
pour que les gens se disent : "Ouah, en fait, c'est multiple".
Nous, le challenge qu'on voulait faire cette année,
c'est de se dire et de montrer aux gens
que c'était possible,
même quand tu viens de sous-cultures
ou que tu viens de l'art underground
ou que tu viens d'un truc qui vient du graffiti,
de toutes ces sous-cultures,
qu'en fait, ça peut être aussi chiadé
qu'un Beaubourg ou un truc comme ça.
Ce n'est pas parce que tu fais du street art
que t'es obligé d'être un schlague
avec une tireuse à bière
et pas faire les efforts
pour montrer ta propre culture.
Je me suis vu être vieux avec une canne
en train de graffer sur un train.
Je le ferai.
C'est important.
Franchement, sinon... mes enfants ne seront pas fiers.